Resentment for secure to comment on the
apparently well established new.
This idea that men have a collective
common collective interests and women
have a separate common collective
interests class interest in these
interests.
Are they to conflict?
There's a competition sometimes on a
collective level.
Well,
I think there is competition between men
and women,
but it's nested inside a broader arena.
Cooperation,
you know,
this is another thing that you learned
from reading Psj if you're,
if you're careful this,
but because piaget was smart enough to
understand that there is no dichotomous
opposition between cooperation and
competition.
So you know,
one of the sort of tenants of the kind
of left this mumble jumble that I hate
is that you should.
Kids shouldn't play competitive games,
right?
It should be cooperative games.
It's like,
okay,
let's take that apart.
Let's take hockey.
Is it competitive or cooperative?
Well,
it's competitive.
wait a second.
No one brings a basketball to the hockey
game,
right?
No one brings a chessboard.
Everyone that comes to the hockey game
comes there to play hockey.
That constitutes cooperation.
We'll mutually define the aim or does
any cooperation.
We'll mutually define the aim,
will assign each other rules,
we'll all agree to stick to the roles.
Well,
that's cooperation and if you break the
rules,
what happens to you get stuck in the
penalty box.
You're not playing hockey off you go.
And people,
people go off,
they go sit in the penalty box,
they don't go kill the referee,
they go and sit in the penalty box,
you know,
six foot seven slash 300 pounds.
So okay.
And then you think,
well what about within the team?
Cooperation or competition?
Well,
each team member is trying to be the
best player but it try not passing to
your colleagues and see what happens.
Even if you're really good,
they'll just,
you're just a diva and no one's going to
be happy with,
you know,
they'll put horrible things in your beer
after the game.
So it's cooperation there as well.
And then there's a Meta level of
cooperation which is that everybody's
trying to improve their skills similar
honestly and so that,
that serves a higher order good.
And everyone's trying to learn how to be
a good player so that they can play many
games.
It's like,
well,
we shouldn't play competitive games.
So like you must've been educated at
noisey.
Sad.
It's very sad and it's so,
so ignorant for people who know
something about child development to say
something like that.
It's just what is with you?
Where were you educated?
Or where were you educated is the right
response.
So,
and then so with men and women,
well there is group competition.
For example,
you're competing roughly speaking with
all your classmates,
right?
And some of the women are going to
outshine you.
And so that's,
that's tough for men.
It's particularly tough for men because
it isn't obvious how you compete full
bore with women.
It's not obvious and we don't know how
to solve that problem.